[Music]
on this thursday night ontario's
premiere pulls the emergency brake
the impending province-wide shutdown
we're now fighting
a new enemy what difference will it make
and why some doctors say it's not enough
to stop the spread of dangerous variants
vaccines are hot commodities so why are
some doses being
dumped any waste is a problem and it's a
challenge
the mistakes that cause waste and the
patchwork of plants to prevent it
an incredible story of survival he's a
tough little guy
how did this three-year-old survive lost
in the woods for more than three days
plus happy april fool's day a parental
prank and
a mystery solved on mars
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is april 1st but the third wave of
this pandemic is no joke
after weeks of warnings the more
transmissible variants are spreading
fast and
with a record number of ontarians now in
intensive care
ontario's premier finally pulled what he
calls an emergency break
this is a new pandemic we're now
fighting
a new enemy the new variants
are far more dangerous than before
starting saturday at midnight and for
four weeks all of ontario will be under
tighter public health
restrictions but it is not the stricter
stay-at-home order
icu doctors and the province's own
science advisors say
is essential to save lives whole
families are now showing up in intensive
care
with the new variants that are both more
contagious and more dangerous
we're seeing situations where whole
families end up in intensive care
all at the same time new modeling
released today shows where this is
headed variants now account for 67
percent of all new cases and
younger people are now ending up in the
hospital the risk of icu admission has
doubled
and the risk of death is 1.5 times
higher for the b-117 variant now
the dominant strain in ontario vaccines
are not reaching the highest
risk communities and are rolling out far
too slowly to have any impact on the
spread of the variants
toronto and peel where case counts are
rising fast
have already been under tight public
health restrictions for weeks
and it's not working so is the so-called
emergency break
too little too late travis stanraj has
our top story tonight
ontario will pull the emergency brake
for the entire province ontario premier
doug ford says this
was his only option a 28-day
province-wide shutdown
an attempt to deal with rapid spread of
variants of concern
and record high icu admissions we need
to do this
i know there's a lot of people that just
want to go out there and
open up and know they don't believe this
varying can be passed i'm sorry
the decision comes after medical experts
have warned for weeks
stronger measures were needed in just
two days between march 26th and 28th
case rates increased by 7.7 percent to
101 cases per 100 000 people
i've signed 27 death certificates for
patients who died of covenant
critical care physician dr michael
warner along with 152
other icu physicians sent this letter to
the province warning
we cannot rely on the public health
measures framework it did not contain
the less infectious less deadly original
variant in wave 2
and it will not be enough to protect us
from vocs in wave 3.
there needs to be an acknowledgment that
the plans that were laid for wave 2
was dealing with a different pandemic
wave 3 is a new disease
as part of the new restrictions indoor
and outdoor dining are prohibited
gyms nail salons barber shops and bars
will be shut down
non-essential retail is limited to 25
capacity
most sports are prohibited and outdoor
gatherings are now capped at five people
the government has provided money to
restaurants
but personal services have been thrown
aside completely
we've just been left hanging with
nothing and here we go again
with nothing for business owners right
across the province this feels like
groundhog day
schools in ontario will remain open part
of learning is actually being
socializing and being with their friends
when pushed for why more wasn't done
sooner ontario's chief medical officer
was defensive so i have to first
say i don't agree it's a failure in gray
zones where it's already a lockdown type
situation like here in toronto there
won't be much in terms of substantial
changes
other than patios shutting down experts
agree
the focus needs to shift now to speeding
up
vaccinations and also curbing spread in
racialized communities and essential
workplaces
something the province has struggled to
do so far donna
travis danraj in toronto thank you
vaccines are not rolling out fast enough
to stop this third wave
here's where we stand with vaccinations
in canada now over 5.8 million vaccine
doses have been administered
by the end of this week canada will have
distributed 9.5 million doses
more than one million doses of the
pfizer biotech vaccine are expected to
arrive each week through
april and may 590 000 moderna doses that
were delayed last week are now expected
to arrive tomorrow
morning and the federal government says
the 1.5 million doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine coming from the u.s
will be distributed to the provinces and
territories by saturday
a further 300 thousand astrazeneca doses
from the kovacs program
are expected in the coming days those
are the big picture numbers as many
canadians know trying to get a shot can
be a frustrating
sometimes haphazard process and as
heather urix west discovered some
precious doses
are going to waste i'm scared but
excited
natalie norman didn't expect to get the
kovid 19 vaccine
so soon it's not yet her turn but the
toronto woman was able to get immunized
last weekend
after signing up on a standby list for
shots left over
at the end of the day i had 30 minutes
they were like can you be here in 30
minutes i got there in about 37.
with limited supply each vial of covid19
vaccine
is precious a dose squandered is a dose
kept out of someone's arm
we reached out to canada's seven largest
provinces to find out how much vaccine
has been wasted so far only alberta
quebec
and manitoba provided numbers quebec's
loss rate is the lowest at .04 percent
or 552 doses lost alberta sits at 0.2
losing about 1 269 doses
while manitoba was a little higher at
0.9 percent
with a loss of 1 653 doses of vaccine
in a global pandemic any waste is you
know
a problem and it's a challenge there are
three kinds of mistakes that lead to
vaccine loss
human error like a dropped file
equipment failure
or mismanaged supply losses are minimal
with the first two
but if supply is mismanaged then the
losses can be great
we have to have more flexibility and
agility so that we don't have 500 000
doses sitting in a fridge expiring
you know over a date that that would
just be heartbreaking
some people have said you know it's not
that big a deal as long as the vaccines
end up in arms and i would really
counter that from an ethical point of
view
ethicist kerry bowman says efforts to
prevent vaccine waste need to continue
to prioritize those most
at risk it's why some provinces have put
strict standby policies in place alberta
health says pharmacies
have been told waiting lists must
prioritize those who are either now
or will soon be eligible
but we called around and quickly found
not all alberta pharmacies are on the
same page no we're just kind of doing
first come first serve at the end of the
day
do you have to be part of the
eligibility pool then or is it sort of
open to
anybody first come first serve at that
point it's sort of open
a lucky break for those who can get it
but also undoubtedly a source of
frustration
for those left to wait heather eurex
west global news
calgary canadian health officials say a
delay in the u.s over a bad batch of the
johnson and johnson vaccine shouldn't
impact its distribution to canada
an ingredient mix-up at a baltimore
production plant forced the company to
throw away up to 15 million doses
johnson johnson says they did not meet
quality standards but
never got to the filling and finishing
stages of the manufacturing process the
company which operates the facility
emergent biosolutions has been flagged
in the past for things like
cracked vials and mold canada is
expecting to receive the first of 10
million johnson and johnson doses
by the end of this month pfizer biontech
now says its vaccine is 100 effective
against the virus in south africa where
a contagious variant was first
discovered
the company issued a press release
saying its data from phase 3 clinical
trials also shows the vaccine is
91 percent effective at preventing covet
19 up to
six months after the second dose that's
slightly lower
than the 95 percent efficacy first
reported
in november well if you feel like the
vaccine rollout is happening too slowly
here in canada consider
europe the world health organization
said today europe is being unacceptably
slow
and is prolonging the pandemic the who
says roughly 10 percent of people in
europe have received a single dose and
just
4 percent are fully protected with two
doses it says cases are rising in all
but one
age group people aged 80 and older
france has gone into another
national lockdown and other countries
are nervously watching this third wave
take hold crystal commansing reports
a trip to the market will again become a
highlight
schools are closing for a month and a
national curfew will keep people
indoors from 7 p.m until 6 a.m
i wish they had just confined us in a
more serious lockdown earlier
french president emmanuel macron had
been avoiding another
round of national restrictions but the
pandemic
forced his hand this week more than 5
thousand covit 19 patients were being
treated in french icus
pressures doctors haven't faced in
nearly a year
italy is also plagued with rising
infections
a three-day lockdown has been ordered
for the easter long weekend
unless we fight against this virus we're
all
dead says this man
the number of lives lost has been
climbing for five weeks
the 14-day average according to the
european center for disease control
is 489 deaths per 100 000 people
since the beginning of the pandemic
public health measures
have been weighed against politics and
you see this internal argument in
germany for example
and changing direction wanting to
restrict and then rolling back because
of political pressure
linda bold is a professor of public
health and says governments
keep getting it wrong we've
unfortunately had preventable deaths as
a result
she says the current wave is made worse
because
eu nations have only vaccinated about
11.6 percent of the population
with a first dose i think they've been
really hesitant to
lay down the law no one likes a lockdown
but they do reduce the spread of the
virus
taking pressure off health systems
crystal gomansing global news
london two little girls are in u.s
custody tonight after people smugglers
dropped them over a four meter high wall
along the u.s mexico border
and a warning the video may be
disturbing for some viewers
a u.s border patrol camera captured it a
person believed to be a smuggler climbs
the barrier and dangles one child
then drops her and then does the same
with a second child
the smuggler then climbs down the
mexican side and runs away
the girls aged three and five are
sisters from ecuador
and they were not injured two months
after the military
coup in myanmar myanmar rather
protesters are still being killed there
at least
521 people are now known to have died
including at least 43 children the
number of children
killed has more than doubled in the past
12 days that's according to the
organization save the children
the human rights groups also says 15
children under the age of 16
are among the dead the youngest known
victim a six-year-old girl was
reportedly shot during a raid on her
home
and a 13 year old boy was reportedly
shot in the back of the head as he tried
to
run away from soldiers seven of hong
kong's leading pro-democracy campaigners
were found guilty today of
unlawful assembly they participated in a
massive march in august of 2019 and it
triggered a violent crackdown
on demonstrators media tycoon jimmy ly
the founder of
pro-democracy newspaper apple day and
martin lee who founded the opposition
democratic party
and is often referred to as hong kong's
father of democracy
were both found guilty of organizing the
unauthorized event
more than a million people turned out
it is the latest blow to hong kong's
democracy movement
the maximum sentence is five years in
jail
the fight for racial equality after
george floyd's death
coming up the reckoning and reform in
the u.s
it was another emotional day at the
murder trial of a former minneapolis
police officer accused of killing george
floyd
courtney ross floyd's girlfriend
testified through tears about the first
time they met
while floyd was working as a security
guard at a shelter
so it came to me
and uh
what is this great deep
southern voice raspy
he's like sis you okay sis
and i wasn't okay
ross is the first person who knew floyd
personally to testify at the trial
part of her testimony included how she
and floyd struggled to overcome opioid
addiction
both floyd and i are our
our story uh it's
it's a classic story of
uh how many people get addicted to
opioids
we both suffered from chronic pain
derek chovin is facing a number of
charges related to floyd's death last
year he's pleaded not guilty to all
those charges
this trial is being followed with
intense interest across the u.s and
around the world
the video of floyd's death while in
police custody sparked an uprising and a
reckoning over racial injustice
and in the u.s it's brought about some
of the most dramatic reforms since the
civil rights era
jackson proskow reports and a warning
some of the video in his story
is disturbing it was the moment the
world finally refused to look
away letting out a collective gasp as
george floyd took his final breaths
under the knee of a police officer
that video brought to life the the
the truths that we've been telling for
for decades
in this country and it took a video of
a black man being murdered on camera
millions marched and demanded action
months after the protests faded american
life has been forever changed by those
nine
agonizing minutes of video there are
times at which
the video is so clear and
incontrovertible that people have to
engage it in a different way
thirty years ago another tape showed the
beating of rodney king at the hands of
los angeles police
it seemed like it might be a
transformational moment but
hope gave way to a long list of names
many now familiar
like michael brown ahmad aubry brianna
taylor
and george floyd there was finally this
large ground swell
that coincided with the pandemic
and the global economic downturn and so
you see
disproportionate impact in multiple
systems
coinciding in the last 10 months the
black lives matter movement went
mainstream
corporations made public commitments to
diversity
politicians everywhere discussed once
taboo subjects like police reform
and reparations you're hearing these
things that are like
were super radical ideas in the past
that are just like
normalized the question is whether those
impacts will fade over time
immediately after floyd's death polls
showed 60 percent of americans believed
it was murder
all these months later that number sits
at just 36 percent
broken down by race there's a sharp
divide 64 percent of black respondents
believe it was murder
compared to just 28 percent of white
respondents
the anguish on display at the trial of
former officer derek shovin
may rip open wounds that have still not
healed
reigniting the push for equality as
americans are reminded
that for many it still hasn't been
achieved
jackson prosco global news washington
stakes on a plane still ahead how can
you tell if it's a prank
or for real
you're watching global national
[Music]
april 1st is the day for pranks but it's
not always easy to tell what's a joke
and
what's not eating on a plane that
doesn't actually take off for example
japan's all nippon airways cleared this
flight for lunch
but not for takeoff yes it is for real
for about 680
diners can enjoy a first-class seat on a
plane parked on a tokyo airport
runway the airline calls it a restaurant
with wings
it was only going to last one day but it
sold out so
they're expanding it and some jokes
today were real like these boys who got
a breakfast surprise look at their faces
when they discovered their bowls of
cheerios were
frozen i'm pretty sure sam and leo
mullen who are sons of our ottawa bureau
manager brian mullen
will find a way to get back at their
parents for this
and this is a mystery solved the
canadian space agency has discovered
where all those single socks that go
missing in the dryer end up
on mars it turns out the space agency
tweeted the news that the perseverance
rover found a pile on the red planet
but the hashtag april fools does make it
all a little suspicious
search party success next how did a
three-year-old survive outside
for more than three days
it's impossible to imagine what the
parents of a missing three-year-old must
have gone through
their son jude disappeared on sunday in
the woods north of kingston ontario
the weather was cold and blustery police
and volunteers looked everywhere for him
and as they were beginning to wind down
that search yesterday
an officer spotted him abigail beeman
has the remarkable story
of survival this is jude's favorite
place
chris fisher has lived on this 200-acre
wooded rural property for nearly 40
years
he thinks his grandson's survival is
unbelievable
it's just amazing he survived
i don't even know if i would have lived
for that long
on sunday three-year-old jude layton
went missing here
police and volunteer crews combed woods
and water
day and night at times temperatures were
below freezing
it's a very treacherous area if you
wander off you know you can you can
it's quite easy to get lost even i've
been turned around on the property
myself from
sunday all the way to wednesday this
clearing that's empty now
was full with people with vehicles
fisher says two helicopters landed here
until the best moment on wednesday when
through that clearing
officers brought jude home on an atv
that's the best day i've had in the opp
in 25 years it was constable scott
mcnamee's birthday when he got the call
to help
he searched for three days it was rocky
it was steep
i'll be honest i did not think that a
three-year-old almost four-year-old
would be able to get that far back there
then less than a kilometer from the
family compound
mcnames spotted something blue another
officer ran
up ahead he said he's here he was lying
down on the stomach and then
jude the little boy raised his head and
opened his eyes and he said and he's
alive
mcnamee says jude was wet but warm
he thinks his wool sweater may have
saved him he asked for some water
he's a tough little guy for sure the
last year
has been just horrendous for everybody
and
this is something that should be
uplifting to
to everybody across the country jude is
in hospital with his parents still being
checked out
the family is so grateful for everyone's
support and for an unbelievably happy
outcome
at a time when everyone can use an extra
smile
abigail beeman global news south
frontinak ontario
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada
is this great grey owl in foothills
alberta
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye